Игорь А.: Смотри, я сделал такой интерактивный кабинет в двух словах. Если скинешь мне ленд, я посмотрю, то надо будет строить вход для партнеров. Либо это отдельная страница, я просто ленд сам
Игорь А.: не видел, как там он устроен.
Игорь А.: Стандартная наша форма, когда отправляешь письмо, тебе приходит код, ты заходишь. Это авторизация для партнеров. Партнером может стать любой. По поводу того слоя, где ты спрашивал,
Игорь А.: как моя организация, не организация. Слушай, ну да, получается, видишь, сейчас я секундочку открою, наверное, другой файл, кто может быть партнером. Ну или так на словах проговорю,
Игорь А.: что по сути любая роль ей может быть присвоен партнер. То есть это может быть и эксперт, и ученик, и там, ну, в общем, блогер какой -нибудь, неважно. То есть партнером может стать любой,
Игорь А.: кто хочет перепродавать наши продукты. Вопрос в том, как, например, будет распределяться вот эта комиссия, мы тоже там с ребятами общались, что нам, если это физлицо, то мы, конечно,
Игорь А.: не можем быть за него налоговым агентом, Мы можем просто ему деньги начислять на счет, и он может пользоваться нашими услугами внутри. То есть это чаще всего, скорее всего, подойдет
Игорь А.: для тех, кто является нашими, так сказать, клиентами. Но это тоже потом обсуждаемо, скорее всего, в ручном режиме, если кому -то надо будет вывести партнерские деньги, каким -то образом
Игорь А.: мы там перезачтемся. Но лучше, чтобы имели юридический статус. Ну и так как мы опробуем это все в России, юридические статусы это ИП, самозанятые, ИОО, то есть мы можем выводить на
Игорь А.: эти компании деньги, то есть отправлять по оферте какой -нибудь, по договору официально, то есть с закрывающими документами и так далее. То есть в каких -то исключительных случаях,
Игорь А.: скорее всего, мы можем тоже физлицам, как я чуть выше сказал, но это нужно там обсуждать, потому что налог мы все равно платим. То есть у российского ИП 6 % налог при достижении 20
Игорь А.: миллионов, еще плюс 5 % НДС. И в связи с этим нам лучше, конечно, все проводить в белую. Вот это такой ретический момент озвучил. Значит,
Игорь А.: здесь так сказать онбординг, то есть кто, чем занимаетесь, то есть здесь может быть вообще блогер, там не важно кто там, просто мамочка в декрете, не важно номер там и почта. Правила
Игорь А.: приняли, пошли дальше на онбординге. Вот как раз таки то, что говорил, да, самозанятый индивидуальный предприниматель, ну слэш ООО можно. Вот, мы здесь сейчас не будем в глубину лезть
Игорь А.: а -ля какое у вас там налогообложение. Главное, что у нас налогообложение сейчас 6%. Если мы перешагнем порог в 20 миллионов и НДС 5%, мы тогда будем менять, пока заморачиваться над
Игорь А.: этим не надо. Это я зачем опять же вот этот флоу сейчас тебе рассказываю, потому что если, например, у нас партнер ООО с НДС, и мы с НДС 5%, а у него НДС 20%, то там идет у него перезачет
Игорь А.: этого НДС. Мы как бы ему выплачиваем деньги с НДС, и ему это хорошо. То есть НДСные компании любят работать с НДСными компаниями, так им деньги на 20 % легче. То есть последний, кто
Игорь А.: оказывает услугу, ну по сути, к кому пришли деньги последнему в цепочке, тот платит НДС. А все предыдущие контрагенты в цепочке этот НДС перекладывают на последнего, к кому придут эти
Игорь А.: деньги. Поэтому такой
Даниил: интересный налог. Просто проговорил как минимум. Да, ну то есть смотри, у физических лиц и у самозанятых, у них вывод на номер карты, там счета.
Игорь А.: Понятное дело, здесь это все в сокращенном варианте, но нужно будет там BIC, вот все эти банковские реквизиты подгружать. То есть физлицо от самозанятого чем отличается? Что самозанятый
Игорь А.: еще выбивает чек. То есть мы ему, например, отправили деньги, к нему пришли, и он нам должен прислать чек. То есть он тоже платит при зачислении от юрлица и ИП 6%, при зачислении денег
Игорь А.: от физлица 4%. Но мы как ИП будем платить, поэтому нам чек с 6 % нужен будет. Вот, ну, индивидуальный предприниматель либо ООО, там у них тоже, я дополню здесь всеми, так сказать, реквизитами,
Игорь А.: которые нужны для подключения такого партнера. Вот, тут смотри, какой момент не затрагивается. В работе с индивидуальными предпринимателями и юрлицами есть еще ЭДО, электронный документ
Игорь А.: оборот. Мы вообще, скорее всего, в эту сторону не смотрели, и будем по мере необходимости, там, подключим этот контур диадок, там, как -то посмотрим уже потом интеграции, можно ли будет
Игорь А.: сюда там все эти интеграции подгружать. То есть на старте мы, я просто проговариваю, что в эту сторону тоже будет система расширяться, если все запустится и пойдут деньги. Но мы сейчас
Игорь А.: это опускаем. Но рано или поздно это сделаем.
Даниил: Говорю, да, да, да, понял. Да,
Игорь А.: то есть рано или поздно это нужно будет сделать, если это все запустится, потому что как бы вручную каждого партнера, кто бы этим не занимался, этим не ты будешь заниматься, в любом
Игорь А.: случае у вас разработка, то есть будет скорее всего человек на это направление поставлен, который будет документооборотом заниматься, либо бухгалтер, то там можно закопаться, то есть
Игорь А.: это не ручная работа точно. Но я проговариваю, что развитие будет в этом направлении. Дальше. По условиям. Мы пришли к такой формуле, что партнер получает 35 % от стоимости, которую
Игорь А.: платит семья. Есть минимальная цена, по которой договорились делать расчет. Это 20 тысяч рублей. То есть 20 000 рублей это цена, ниже которой сформировать индивидуальную ссылку и предложение
Игорь А.: в кабинете невозможно. Рекомендуемое, чтобы рынок, скажем так, продавал этот продукт, а продукт профориентация автоматическая. Пока что Максим говорит, если будут продажи, я на первоначальных
Игорь А.: этапах тоже консультации буду брать, чтобы там обратную связь брать, собирать. Но в целом у нас будет без консультации продукт, как он задуман сейчас после скрининга. Рекомендуемая
Игорь А.: цена 35 и верхнюю границу мы отменяем. То есть у нас по сути система такая, чем дороже ты продаешь как партнер, тем больше самостоятельно и зарабатываешь. То есть продаешь дешевле,
Игорь А.: зарабатываешь меньше. И это вот такая приведена таблица по стоимости, которую ты получаешь как партнер. Тут оговорюсь по поводу того, чтобы считалось все правильно для нас. Смотри,
Игорь А.: вот например, партнер привел 20 тысяч рублей. Мы с полной стоимости должны будем заплатить 6%. То есть 6 % это 1200 рублей. То есть мы получается партнеру отдаем 7 и 1200 налоги. У
Игорь А.: нас плюс эквайринг, там всякие расходы. Возьмем это 10 % наши. То есть минус 7 и минус 2. То есть мы получим как компания 11. Но мы заинтересованы в том, чтобы партнер продавал дороже.
Игорь А.: И соответственно и он зарабатывал больше и мы. То есть почему взяли не фиксированную какую -то стоимость для компании, а взяли вот такой процент, потому что там начали считать, и модель
Игорь А.: показывала, что чем больше стоимость программы, тем мы платим больше налог, и в некоторых моментах мы можем даже уйти в минус. То есть условно говоря, если бы мы поставили просто нам
Игорь А.: 20, а все, что выше, то когда налог достигает 20 тысяч рублей, например, кто -то очень дорого продал или за миллион продал, то мы платим 60 тысяч налога плюс эквайринг, то есть мы минус
Игорь А.: 1070 можем получить, нам это не надо. Поэтому такая система. Это я тебе проговариваю, почему именно так.
Игорь А.: Когда ты проектировал потом борт по доходу, ты понимал, что у нас есть расходная часть налога, У нас есть расходная часть эквайринг. Здесь надо будет с Сашей поговорить, потому что
Игорь А.: в эквайринге там тоже есть... Короче, я не знаю, может я сильно глубоко лезу, но проговорить мне кажется это все тоже нужно, потому что это расчет денег компании. В эквайринге есть
Игорь А.: две системы, так сказать, снятия этого процента. Один это система быстрых переводов. Там по -моему 0 ,7 % от стоимости комиссия. И второй это банковский эквайринг. То есть банк, ну
Игорь А.: там, к примеру, там Сбербанк, Альфа -банк, Т -банк, они могут брать, условно говоря, от 1 ,7 до 3 ,5 % за одну сделку, за один чек, в зависимости от условий пакета. И там, условно говоря,
Игорь А.: чем у тебя дороже пакет, тем у тебя эквайринг ниже. Ну, либо там разные механики есть, то есть вот это уже с Сашей мы, что мы тебе предоставим чуть позже информацию. То есть это тоже
Игорь А.: влияет на вот эти вот, знаешь, проценты, которые в итоге компания получит на остаточную стоимость денег. Плюс есть еще стоимость этих денег вывода с ИП, потому что некоторые банки берут,
Игорь А.: например, 1%, кто -то 0%, кто -то там миллион бесплатно себе на карту, а дальше выше. То есть мы вот эти вот уже нюансы будем в P &L, в доход компании считать позже. Но сейчас я проговариваю,
Игорь А.: что такое есть. И поэтому здесь, например, мы в глубину в эту не идем, просто чтобы сейчас не упороться.
Игорь А.: Делаем проще. Я понял. Да, делаем проще. По мере, скажем так, масштаба и проблемы мы будем их уже решать.
Игорь А.: Дальше смотри. В кабинете должен быть новое предложение, которое может сформировать сам партнер. Вот этот ползунок.
Игорь А.: Соответственно, минимальный 20, не знаю, что он 18 сделал. Короче, 20 должен быть минимальный.
Даниил: Не знаю, что он 20 сделал. 18, короче.
Игорь А.: Ну, в общем, от 20 до должна быть, что вот рекомендуемая цена, видишь, и вам начисляться. И к выплате вам вот столько. И как бы человек сам формирует. Можно срок убрать. вот можно там
Игорь А.: назвать это там для там саши
Игорь А.: вот создать предложение вот он там создает это предложение
Игорь А.: соответственно сейчас я назад вернусь пойду по flow вот у него эти предложения видишь есть здесь, они фиксируются, то есть я могу для Саши 2 здесь создать предложение, я не знаю какую
Игорь А.: -нибудь сумму, то есть я пока тут в MVP -120, по -моему, или 150 тысяч, 120 тысяч, но можно, условно говоря, и до 500 поставить этот ползунок, и знаешь, как с такими какими -то
Игорь А.: чтобы было понятно, какая стоимость идет.
Игорь А.: Ладно, пойдем дальше в предложения. Вот эти предложения есть.
Игорь А.: Мы, соответственно, как партнер видит это все, мы даем ему ссылку, то есть он скопировал и по этой ссылке, Как сейчас, например, есть бесплатная, есть одна цена, есть другая. Точно
Игорь А.: так же формируется автоматическая цена, которую партнер сформировал в приглашении. Либо, как у нас есть промокоды, партнер может давать промокод.
Игорь А.: Что здесь дальше может сформироваться? Такой простенький лендинг. там у нас есть по профориентации, можно на него добавить информацию, что это рекомендует какой -то партнер и купить
Игорь А.: за вот эту стоимость. И можно, соответственно, остановить предложение, либо еще какое -то предложение создать. Понятное дело, что лучше его создавать здесь. Почему здесь по 35? Потому
Игорь А.: что это рекомендуемая цена. То есть я думаю, что большинство будут стартовать, конечно, с меньшей, потом с уровнем продаж будут всем продавать по 35 стараться, либо дороже. Но можно
Игорь А.: и не создавать, если это необязательная кнопка. Ну, в общем,
Игорь А.: пусть пока будет, чтобы мы стимулировали их делать как бы рынок все по одной цене. Так, ну, соответственно, следующая страница семьи, я тебе уже по факту ее чуть ранее рассказал. Так,
Игорь А.: по поводу оплат. Значит, статистика у нас вытягивается из метрики, сколько по ссылкам перешло, сколько было там обращение оплат и, соответственно, в каком статусе.
Игорь А.: То есть он понимает, что это там какой -то заказ для такого -то человека от такой -то даты, по такой -то цене начислено. И вот когда, например,
Игорь А.: услуга будет оказана, смотри, у нас здесь правило должно быть такое, что деньги можно выводить через 7 дней после того, как оказана услуга. Ну, то есть это такое, знаешь.
Даниил: Да. Ну, я видел в отчете, да, ты мне штуки дал. Там я, в принципе, это уже и сделал. Я многое сделал из этого. У нас было многое сделано, я еще твои правки, которые ты по презентациям
Даниил: кидал, я их сделал. Вот, касаемо этого тоже, что там услуга должна быть завершена, время должно с этого времени пройти. Все эти моментики я учел. О, супер, супер.
Игорь А.: Ну, в общем, да,
Игорь А.: должен быть, скажем так, общий flow по
Игорь А.: статусам сделки, то есть должен понимать, например, партнер, что там происходит. И вот я там написал по вторникам, можно, например, действительно какой -нибудь день выбрать, тот же
Игорь А.: вторник, и мы просто партнером по вторникам отправляем деньги. Почему один день? Такая бухгалтерская фишка, особенно компании, когда растут, и еще пока ручной труд, мы, возможно, потом
Игорь А.: это правило отменим, но часто бухгалтера говорят, давайте так, мы берем вот один день, платежки все вносим и все оплачиваем. Ну и вот поэтому тоже для тебя. Зачем это делается, как
Игорь А.: бы объясняю, потому что часто так бухгалтера такие. Ну да, на
Даниил: примере ОВБ тоже они вроде бы так делают, выплаты по определенным дням именно.
Игорь А.: Да, типа не хочу заниматься этим всю неделю, давай вот конкретно этой задачей я буду заниматься один день в неделю. Потому что есть еще другие задачи. Так, дальше что у нас?
Игорь А.: Ну это вот рассматриваем кейс возврата. Значит, у нас, если запрос возврата денег, то мы, соответственно,
Игорь А.: должны либо пересчитывать. Но вообще желательно, знаешь, как по поводу возвратов. Видишь, я не думаю, что у нас будет абуз системы, но такой негативный сценарий тоже нужно посмотреть.
Игорь А.: Что, например, мы выплатили, а у нас потом запросили возврат.
Игорь А.: Чтобы не было вот этого всего, я почему -то изначально 14 дней ставил, потому что по закону попросить возврат можно в течение 14 дней. Но у нас по факту должно быть в системе условие,
Игорь А.: что услуга выполнена. Поэтому, опять же, возвращаясь к правилам, я тебе сейчас озвучу, что для меня, скорее всего, идеально, что, например,
Игорь А.: либо закончилась услуга, либо она уже оплачена в течение 14 дней. То есть, вот этот холд на 14 дней, он как будто бы Прямо напрашивается, потому что действительно мы можем через 7 дней,
Игорь А.: вот сегодня пришел человек, сегодня прошел, мы через 7 дней выплатили, а потом еще через 3 дня человек говорит, верните мне деньги. Ну понятное дело, что тут нужно рассматривать, что
Игорь А.: алло, ребят, ну какой возврат, вы же услугу получили, получили. Вот, то есть тут будет в индивидуальном порядке. Ну я надеюсь, что у нас такого не будет всего. Но если будет прецедент,
Игорь А.: нам нужно, чтобы эти 14 дней с момента покупки прошли.
Игорь А.: То есть что наступит быстрее? Либо просто наступило 14 дней с покупки, либо прошло 7 дней после того, как прошли услугу, но уже спустя эти 14 дней. понимаешь
Даниил: да да да ну вот эти в телегу скинул вот эту вот строку я выдернул из отчета получается по формулировке именно вот ну что то да
Игорь А.: да да да да
Игорь А.: да супер так
Игорь А.: панель партнера соответственно
Игорь А.: общее его состояние. Ну и по сути все. Помощь еще есть, например,
Игорь А.: тикет. Тикет, я думаю, что нужно будет создать почту, либо вот там есть почта у нас. Но я такой приверженец, чтобы не путать все это в один поток, там, где у нас на Rambler почта. Скорее
Игорь А.: всего на Main Experts, там какой -нибудь надо будет партнерс собака, main experts, там, ком или онлайн, вот, и туда пусть прилетают запросы,
Даниил: чтобы... Ну, у нас еще есть, если что, работает этот, как он, обсуждение в телеге называется, топ -кит, или как он там называется, ну, типа беседы, и туда вот эти вот запросы могут
Даниил: прилетать, то есть мы можем настроить, чтобы оно также улетало просто в телегу нам, как в
Игорь А.: фото. Там, где лиды сейчас падают,
Даниил: да? Ну да, вот сейчас я тебе покажу, где -то за скринью у меня он был, поддержка, вот поддержка MainExpert.
Даниил: Я открываю, и оно выглядит так. Я могу
Игорь А.: тебе дать
Даниил: доступ
Игорь А.: к экрану.
Даниил: Сейчас.
Даниил: Так, демонстрация.
Даниил: Вот, смотри, вот этот вот я делал, получается, в формате группы. И у нас получается вот здесь вот я добавлял Сашу и Вадима, ну и бот наш тут добавлен. Короче, человек, когда оставляет
Даниил: запрос, он вот таким вот чатом делается, и мы на него можем отвечать, соответственно, брать в работу и отвечать. там условно какой -нибудь идти берем такой вот тема и так далее от какого
Даниил: пользователя ну и мы можем ответить ему ему придет ответ то есть это также у нас хранится в базе данных и можем это отслеживать то есть не обязательно для этого там почту использовать
Даниил: такой формат мне кажется даже будет более удобный
Игорь А.: но
Даниил: в целом да согласен
Игорь А.: просто не все пользуются телеграммом да есть большая аудитории особенно в европе которая не пользуется телеграма рада и это
Даниил: это не к тому что им telegram пользоваться нам пользоваться им то приходит ответ там в личном кабинал им нашим на а это только мы просто отвечаем ответ он приходит там
Игорь А.: супер
Игорь А.: слушай ну хорошо давай тогда так бы эту систему не писать но хорошо так
Игорь А.: ну по сути может вопросы какие то есть да нет на самом деле я
Даниил: очень много там читал потому что ты кидал и в принципе я уже там все моменты закрыл кроме вот как раз получается
Даниил: панели то что ты показал партнером кабинета
Игорь А.: партнера в
Даниил: остальном принципе там уже все что реализовано. Единственное, что я тебе говорил про организации, это, наверное, ты чуть -чуть не так понял, про что я говорил, у нас система организации
Даниил: закладывалась в том направлении, что мы в дальнейшем позиционируем себя не только как одну организацию на платформе MainExperts, а как типа платформа, в которую могут приходить какие
Даниил: -то еще дополнительные агентства, школы и так далее. и у каждой такой организации может быть своя условно ставка партнерская. И ее можно указывать. Допустим, какая -то организация указала
Даниил: 30%, какая -то 50%, какая -то 10%. Вот об этом я там говорил.
Игорь А.: Но в целом... Извини, продолжай, я думал, закончу.
Даниил: И то, что партнер приводит, получается, пользователя именно в какую -то конкретную организацию, и отчисления идут от нее. То есть, если он купил у другой организации уже, там отчисления
Даниил: не идут. И это тоже влияет на партнерку сильно, чтобы мы лишние отчисления никакие не делали там партнеру, который привел не в ту организацию.
Игорь А.: Слушай, здесь нужно подумать, потому что смотри,
Игорь А.: была такая идея, что партнеры могут рекомендовать не только, например, профориентацию, которая сейчас есть, а любой продукт на платформе и от него получать. То есть это получается вообще
Игорь А.: отдельная надстройка, которая не привязывает получение денег в зависимости от организации. То есть это отдельная сущность, отдельный слой получается. который ну вот смотри сейчас пример
Игорь А.: приведу например я профориентолог или там я учитель английского я привел пользователя это мы сейчас начинаем с профориентации но потом например я понимаю что провел профориентацию еще
Игорь А.: и на этом заработал и или ссылку скинул там заработал на И там нужно будет ученику, которого я привел, подтянуть математику. А ты учитель математики. У нас дальше будет какое развитие?
Игорь А.: Например, ты учитель математики, но ты тоже в партнерскую программу заходишь. И для уроков ты, например, ставишь... Это отдельный слой, мы просто его сейчас пока не проговариваем, но
Игорь А.: мы уже его обсуждали, как это будет работать. Ты, например, как учитель математики ставишь на свои предметы, вот в партнерский marketplace, скажем так, ты готов отдавать партнерам 30
Игорь А.: % или 20%, то есть ты можешь сам поставить сколько процентов ты готов отдавать в партнерскую сеть. Например, 5 % заберет платформа и 25 % партнер, который приведет. И вот я, понимая,
Игорь А.: что ты классный эксперт, у тебя высокий процент, я порекомендую, например, дальше пойти к тебе. И я буду зарабатывать на том, что ты проводишь занятия, но ты уже являешься другой организацией.
Игорь А.: Соответственно, партнерская программа, она не должна привязывать доход только к организации.
Даниил: Я понял. Ну да, да, да. Это такой вполне логичный сценарий.
Даниил: Вот.
Даниил: Ну, это по большей части, да, нужно прорабатывать, когда у нас будет какой -то набор организаций, а не так, что мы там одна организация и все. на платформе. Часто в любом случае мы
Даниил: одной организацией, и у каждой организации есть свой набор экспертов. Допустим, в начале мы в любом случае идем таким образом, что мы как одна организация со своим пулом экспертов.
Даниил: Эксперт по математике, эксперт по другим урокам и так далее. И это в рамках одной организации работает, и никаких проблем не возникает. Проблемы могут возникнуть, когда мы даем возможность
Даниил: регистрироваться другим экспертом как отдельным организациям у нас. Тогда уже надо будет проработать детальнее.
Игорь А.: Да, ну я тебе тоже накинул этот контекст, чтобы понимал, что там потом при развитии платформы партнерка будет шире, чем просто в пределах одной организации.
Игорь А.: Это знаешь, вот, но эксперты, они немножко побаиваются конкуренции, а по факту, если друг друга будут рекомендовать, неважно какой они организации привязаны, то есть они будут просто
Игорь А.: зарабатывать больше в этом интересе. Это и партнерская программа.
Игорь А.: Ну, понятное дело, что там мы тоже будем ограничивать, наверное, не больше 30%. Потому что, условно говоря, 50 -70 % от своего дохода отдавать партнеру, это, наверное, уже... Продолжение
Игорь А.: следует...